a pretty big day tomorrow all right so
it's 6 43
now usually we have our morning cup of
joe's segment with sheriff joe lombardo
on wednesdays
he's running for governor as you may
know so now we have mornings with metro
and today we are joined live by
assistant sheriff brett zimmerman
live to talk all things law enforcement
sir good to see you this morning how you
doing
hey good morning thank you for having me
of course good to see you again
all right so we've been dealing with a
heat wave especially last week super hot
temperatures across the valley
obviously we've just started summer and
we always have the issue with
what do you do if there's a child or an
animal that you see left in a hot car
what should we as the public do and then
what would metro do in that circumstance
well what we always say this the public
is our eyes and ears when when a police
officer isn't around
and it's always great when the public
calls when they see
a uh a child or a pet in a in a hot
vehicle
you know a a big example is say last
week when it was 11516 degrees out your
car is always going to be
25 degrees more hotter and for those of
you who've ever parked parked on asphalt
in a parking lot
you realize how hot your vehicle gets
the way we respond
to those is uh we'll usually get that
call we encourage people to call 9-1-1
it's a serious issue
our officers will roll code which is
lights and siren to get to the scene as
immediately as they can
they'll uh will request medical and when
the officers get there we'll assess the
situation
if it's an absolute emergency and the
child looks like in distress the officer
may break the window
if it's something where the child is
just sitting in the car and can unlock
the door
or looks that looks like they're
coherent we may attempt to find the
parent
uh in that short period of time it is a
crime
it's a form of abuse or neglect and the
maximum is you you you could
have a criminal charge filed against you
or be arrested
for that crime for leaving your child in
or pet in that hot vehicle
it gets right back to the if you see
something say something mantra that i
know a lot of law enforcement uses
let's switch gears sir let's talk about
something that we all saw
last week and that was a video from law
enforcement of terrell rhodes
the suspect in that amari nicholson that
horrible case of the two-year-old who
died
rhodes the video shows he grabbed a gun
from detectives
in the interview room during the process
how does something like that happen
especially when a murder suspect's in
custody that was a dangerous situation
yeah uh you know that was a horrible
case all around for
the family for our detectives and for
the community
uh we we you know in that situation you
know
to address it exactly what had happened
was our officers had been interviewing
the suspect roads
and during that interview they had
stepped outside
those rooms are under video surveillance
at all times
the officers are within policy to have
their guns in that interview room
but they observed the suspect roads uh
messing with the handcuffs
while they were outside of that room
when they went in to confront him as
you're watching the video
you saw what occurred he was able to
pull one of the officer's guns
out of the holster and our officers were
able to quickly take that situation
under control
and and we were able to have a have a
desirable outcome instead of a deadly
force outcome
there also we train for that
we have our close quarter type scenarios
we we do firearms training we do
defensive tactics training
but in an incident like this our
critical incident review team
we'll take a look at that review it look
at things
look at our policies look at our
procedures look at things we can do
better
because we always like to come out of
these things with better training and
better tools for our officers
when they deal with situations like that
you see that video that could have gone
so bad so fast there thankfully it was
safely handled
let's switch gears also and talk about
an increase another sad situation here
we're seeing more auto pedestrian
fatalities on the roads here in las
vegas
what are you seeing at metro police this
is an ongoing issue in the valley for
for decades what can we do to try and
make keep ourselves safe
well uh we we're up in fatals this year
year-to-date
uh we're up about 38 uh 62 i believe to
45 at this time last year
one of the one of the factors is that
you know the first the second three
months of last year april may and june
nobody was out driving this year a lot
of people have come out the
lockdown's over everybody's getting
vaccinated and we're back on the
roadways
what we have seen is what we do is there
are different things we do
first thing we do is we use our data we
go to our high accident
intersections we know in each area
command which area command has the most
motorcycle fatals the most pedestrian
fatals the most excessive speed fatals
and we gear
our enforcement in regards to that we
have a
joining forces uh team that that is all
members of the valley not only metro
but henderson north las vegas nhp even
school police assists us on that
and we cut we we've gotten more bang for
our buck on what's called dui blitzes
in the past we used to do checkpoints
we'd have a lot of resources out there
cars would line up we didn't really get
a lot of uh
you know people could turn around do
whatever they needed to do on a dui
blitz we use that data
we go to that certain area and we're
able to do more enforcement
a lot of things our major cause is
pedestrian error
uh and that's where it's basically
jaywalking or someone's out of a
crosswalk
one of the things that's hindering us
now is ab403
where jaywalking has now become a civil
infraction
so jaywalking is no longer a crime so an
officer cannot stop
arrest or cite for jaywalking and one of
the tools we had in regards to
jaywalking is it's not for us to do that
it's more for education and the
education standpoint is you educate the
pedestrian and not jaywalk
but it's a horrific situation for the
normal citizen that's driving down the
street minding their business driving
safely
that pedestrian jumps out and they're
involved in a fatal accident that
affects
that person in their vehicle also not
only the pedestrian that was killed
but the person who's driving that
affects your entire life it could
because you've killed somebody in an
accident
that wasn't your fault it is an ongoing
issue assistant sheriff brett zimmerman
we do appreciate you joining us this
morning
if you at home have a question for metro
police submit it at eight newsnow dot
com you can find out if your question is
answered every wednesday